this is a story about divisions and
dividing lines and it begins with this a
slim pathway of cobbles along the
streets of Berlin because we're now
there are stones there used to be a wall
building work on the Berlin Wall began
suddenly in 1961 a barrier to divider a
city and nation and even a continent
millions of people found themselves
trapped in a new repressive country
peter bieber was 16 when the ball went i
think how crazy it was to do that only
that the people can't leave the land he
escaped in 1970 but then returned across
the wall to help eleven other people get
to the west on his final rescue mission
peter was caught by the East German
secret police and sent to prison for
five grueling years I was 27 years and I
think in this moment here I don't know
what happened what will they do with me
eventually the West German government
bought his freedom Peter returned across
the wall and waited for the day when it
would fall in 1989 they opened the wall
that night like for me as a November
tonight's November civ it's a high day
in my life yes yes best day of my life
the campaign to bring down the Berlin
Wall had run for decades mr. Gorbachev
tear down this wall but in 1989 after
months of rumours East Germany simply
dropped all border restrictions anchored
on chegberg was a textile student
growing up in East Germany when she
heard the border to the West had been
opened she rushed to be there to see
what life was like on the other side
lots of hands pulled us up and so we
managed to get on top of it and
everybody was also holding everybody
else and nobody was falling down it was
deep and there on top of this wall it
was then
that I felt for the first time is
actually true we the people we won
and nobody will ever fight us back again
we have won forever so to say now three
decades later she's an MP worried that
reunification still hasn't fulfilled its
own heavy expectations I will definitely
say the reunification has not happened
hundred-percent and it's very easy to
see it if you just measure any
statistics if you color it by numbers
you see where the border was you still
see it you look for unemployment rates
you see the wall you look for income you
look for wealth you see the wall so is
she right our East and West still framed
by a wall that has long since fallen and
what would that mean for Europe's
biggest richest countries thirty years
after it was breached this wall still
has extraordinary symbolic power as a
sign of how politics can divide the
world but it didn't just split Berlin
into this wall also separated East and
West Germany and that profound scar
still hasn't really healed the division
is most obvious when you head east so
we're traveling to a town that is still
struggling with a question of identity
Cottbus you can see the heritage of East
Germany and here reunification brought
pain as well as joy one and a half
million East Germans working in
state-run companies lost their jobs
millions more fled
Carola opened her shop just a month
before the wall came down she's seen how
caucus has changed some people were
definitely hit hard and people who were
unemployed then are receiving lower
pensions now and I think these people
feel bad I think politicians could have
solved this problem better many economic
sectors and cardbus
collapsed after the fall of the war and
because of this many young people leave
after school
your Molloy to follow anhum disaffection
is rife only 38% of people in the East
think German reunification has been a
success but now voters here are moving
away from traditional parties and
instead a growing number are backing a
relatively new party called aft aft
supporters say it voices the concerns of
normal voters its critics say it's
extremist and racist and what's really
notable is that AF D is much more
popular in East Germany than in the West
and now the AFD has added a new message
a defense of East German voters East
Germans are more critical per se they
are more critical because we once saw
our state's collapse and so we say wait
you better pay attention before we
realize that the country is going down
the drain again it is this rhetoric this
idea of people being cheated of chances
that is pulling voters towards the party
discontent rather suits the AFD
right-wing populist people very often
try to victimize themselves as a
democratic society we need to talk about
in just situations yes that is not
justifying right-wing actions and racist
attitudes so what does this mean for the
whole country Christian here is the
German government Commissioner for the
eastern states I asked him if he saw a
FG success as a danger signal yes it's a
kind of warning and you have probably
into East more people who are against
like our immigration politics about our
climate politics and the people don't
want changes they want to stay like
and it is more a stronger signal and
warning in the east and in the West that
you have the same situations not only in
Germany also in the West we have it
everywhere in and word Germany is led by
a Chancellor who grew up in East Germany
the government knows it's got a problem
the question is whether the division is
so entrenched that it may be impossible
to properly unify East and West the
people in West Germany they don't
understand that there is no longer a
West German standard the East German
needs to fulfill
but we need to talk about a new cultural
political point of view of our country
Peter Bieber now teaches young people
about the wall and its place in the
nation's history he wants people to know
the reality of East Germany to resist
any misplaced nostalgia yes that's a big
danger yeah and many people living this
it I in the GDR life for sport and I say
it know that that's not right
fundamentally this wall is really just
concrete and reinforced to steel but
it's symbolic power is mighty and as for
its impact on Germany's life and
politics all that is profound it is
three decades since this wall fell amid
scenes of euphoria but maybe it's been
replaced by something else by an
invisible wall running the length of
Germany and that may prove even harder
to demolish